women initiate 80 of divorces
so so women leave much more if you're
college educated it's 90 percent
yeah so i mean your chance of getting
divorced is quite low and i think that's
because women are more based in feelings
and men are more based in logic because
we're chemically different every single
day based on where we are in our cycle
could i add to that quickly um i do find
it interesting for like how
so many women initiate divorce
whereas
i can't say this is the case for all
abrahamic religions
but in judaism
for example if a man and a woman are
going to get a divorce a woman literally
has to seek permission from their
husbands to get divorced
i'm not saying that that's a good thing
or a bad thing or whatever i'm not here
to judge judaism and their rulings but
it's interesting to me that when we look
at like ancient scripture
it's essentially saying that
a woman when making that choice might be
making that choice
out of their feelings and not being
perhaps objective about the marriage
itself
but obviously women should have
the opportunity to divorce but why is it
that we're seeing such a high divorce
rate and why is it that women are
initiating it more than men are
there's no consequence
yeah
because i mean you can get divorced and
get
child support for 18 years
so do you think divorce is therefore
incentivized yes oh my gosh yeah and and
social media i think specifically for
women i think girls think that on the
other side it's it's a lot happier than
it is because you see a lot of women
like coping on social media and it's
really sad like i'll always see women
talk about oh i'm so happy to be in my
30s and single and alone and i'm just
like yeah okay
even though statistically study after
study after study will say that if you
make it to 45 and you're still alone and
single like that is the least happy
group wow
but
i mean that's just kind of how women
cope and so it's almost like marketing
the single life to the married women
do you think men would initiate divorce
more if there weren't these grave
consequences
for example child support yes et cetera
taken off they are taking half
i don't understand why girls get to take
half like you can get a job too like i
don't i don't get it yeah i don't get
that even it's a bit weird
do you think it's purely because um how
it's been back in the day
women taking half is based on the fact
that they would have the kids as well
yeah
i think that's what it was
and men are the providers could you say
that again women would have the kids
in
in situation of divorce in back in the
day
when are we talking about no no not that
far back sorry okay okay okay
uh probably 20 30 years okay okay okay
yeah yeah yeah
but
because before that let's be honest like
women were the property of their fathers
before until they became the property of
their husbands do you get what i'm
saying like women in the west have only
had the right to have property in i
think the 19th century or maybe the 18th
century yeah
funny thing is though like
um if we look back before that
you know we're looking at women being
property like i say we're looking uh say
when islam was initially originated that
was like the first religious tradition
that gave women the right for property
in situations of divorce a man is
supposed to provide what's called a maha
which is like a security when they get
married
so a man is supposed to give that woman
assets in case of a divorce
so that that woman can rely on those
assets
but that doesn't mean she's entitled to
half his
you know stuff
it just means that he has provided that
security in case of a divorce and if she
divorces that's totally her choice and
she can run off with that mahad which is
rightfully hers and in even in a
marriage her money is her money whereas
the man's money is everyone's money it's
the family's money do you get what i'm
saying so it's kind of a different it's
a different thing
but i digress
did you know the top five richest women
in the world made their bags through
divorce
wow
that is so messed up
um so if a girl
wants to have kids right and she doesn't
get the men that she wants
like like oh the men that she wants
don't want her do you think she should
settle for a guy that she doesn't want
no absolutely not
no no
look how many people are in the world
you can find
the one you want
somewhere else well i mean i think if
the men you want constantly don't want
you it means something's wrong with you
so there's probably something wrong with
her
either yeah either she's not either
she's not attractive enough to get it or
something's wrong with her character if
you constantly the men that you want
don't want you
i feel like
there's going to be there's going to be
a guy that does want her like this
there's so many
there are guys there are guys that want
her but not the ones that she wants
oh okay so either she's batting out of
her league
right yeah yeah yeah so i'm saying if if
that
like continues to be the case should she
settle for a guy she doesn't want
if that happens no i still say no
because it's just like
you're not going to be happy if you
don't you're just not going to be happy
and it's just going to be a thing where
okay cool i've settled mm-hmm and you're
still not i'm just you got your kids
cool my dreams are my kids now but
you're not happy yeah so so second
question how much money do you think you
need to retire
at 65.
yeah london
costs
a lot
sorry could you be more specific about
what you mean there so at 65 if you want
to retire and not work till you die okay
but you own your house or something like
that
yes okay
i'll take two million oh you need to
earn a lack of a mortgage we're assuming
that you've paid off your mortgage by
65. yeah okay own your house and in
order for you to live another let's say
30 more years yeah how much money would
you need is this just like bare minimum
yeah
minimum bare minimum oh
two million i'd say
i think
five three male is a good challenge what
about you guys
if it's minimum okay i take about two
yeah two million honestly no idea so yes
he got it's 2.5 million
so and the average women i don't know
what it is in the uk but i know it's
similar the average woman in the us
makes um 35 000 per year in u.s dollars
and i know it's something similar in the
uk when you take the conversion
so
those women that choose not to settle
will end up homeless women are the
largest and like growing homeless
population
wow dumb
so
if they choose not to settle
then i mean their other option and
they're not making close to six figures
the option is die alone and on the
streets
do you think maybe
that the better option would be maybe
get a guy that you're not as attracted
to
i mean it's better than dying homeless
sure
but that's the case
it's no there's no win for her either
way like it's it's just sad regardless
she's like she's gonna be on the street
dining alone and then she doesn't she's
gonna live with the guy for the rest of
her life that she that she doesn't want
and she who she doesn't like so there's
no way i don't think i'm sad i think
it's the consequence of a choice she
made because she the reason she's not
satisfied with the guys on her level is
she's had she's slept with too many guys
that are out of her level so what if she
hasn't yeah or she focused on her career
when she was younger and then decided to
yeah
but
should women not focus on their career
to to a certain extent where they that
they can provide themselves that level
of security financially in case of
divorce and so on obviously in divorces
women get half of the man's staff
but that financial cushion surely that's
a bit of a blessing for a woman to
remain independent if she so chooses to
i think it's a choice that a woman makes
to decide to focus on her career um as
opposed to find a partner at the age
where you would consider a woman being
in her
bue prime as such 24 that's kind of yeah
that kind of age range if she doesn't
want to find a man in that age that's
fair she wants to focus on her career do
she's got to do what she does but more
so than anything there are consequences
that when she gets to the
29 30s she's going to find that the guys
that she once wanted or one could have
or could have are no longer interested
in her maybe
change
maybe what what she what she wanted then
as opposed to like once she's lived her
life figured out like who she is where
she wants to go with like maybe what she
wants in a guy might change well it
typically it typically does i mean like
women look for more long-term security
the older they get yeah um but i think
his point is that a woman's peak like
the most like if you survey men between
the age of like 20 and 80 a woman's peak
attractiveness is somewhere around the
age of 22 or 23.
and you're 50 of your options like so on
dating apps if we took your your matches
from when you were 18 to when you were
30 they go down by 50 percent
from from your early 20s to your 30s wow
so the the problem is if a girl is
dating at a young age she's used to
getting the guys let's say she's a seven
okay so she can attract the guys that
are sevens eights nines and tens
because you know they'll typically deal
with a girl that's a seven
so then she goes through 20 she focuses
on her career she hits 30 she says i'm
ready to get married those guys have no
interest in her because they want the 22
year olds
and then she hits 30 and she she's not
satisfied with the partners that she
gets
so this is all based on like a choice
that she made
which is which is fine i think everyone
should have the right to do what they
want to do but i don't know if we're
always honest about the consequences